foreign
when I was seven years old I embarked on
the biggest adventure of my life
just short of four feet tall I stood
quietly surveilling the airport around
me as I took the first big steps of my
journey
as my parents left me behind I was
overwhelmed by the sounds of rattling
Wheels
smell of recirculated air and the
seemingly endless number of grown-ups
running from place to place
around my neck I felt the light tug of a
lanyard
emblazoned on a bright red background
were the letters u m short for
unaccompanied minor
for the first time I was gonna fly in a
little plane all by myself
however I was a little nervous
as I felt tears of anxiety pooling in my
eyes I tightly squeezed my trusted
blankie into the folds of my chubby
little fingers could use it right now
giving me some temporary relief from my
feelings
immediately my fear was turned to wonder
eyes were drawn to the whirling conveyor
belts all around me I watched as people
struggle to heave their bags on top of
them as if by Magic they were then
sucked into the underbelly of the
airport a black hole covered by some
rubber flaps
where'd they go I thought to myself
how'd they get from a conveyor belt to
where I was going
as I was wondering I was whisked away to
the plane and when I arrived at my
destination I once again had my eyes
drawn to the conveyor belts
this time I noticed the reflective
silver folds that cushioned the fall of
newly arriving bags
I sat down and tried to figure out the
mystery of how they got here
I definitely didn't see them on the
plane with me
and they definitely didn't fly here on
their own
and then I'd solved it the bags I'd seen
before had been loaded onto a bus driven
to this new airport and were now falling
into the arms of their respective owners
well my seven-year-old self might have
struggled to understand that plane how
to understand that planes have a cargo
hold he wasn't wrong in struggling to
understand how anything gets from one
place to another
every single day all around the globe
over a hundred thousand flights take off
nearly 90 000 cargo ships power through
the ocean and tens of millions of trucks
transport goods from place to place
the Beating Heart of our globalized
economy as is logistics and Logistics
can be the difference between winning or
losing Wars or time-sensitive vaccines
saving the lives of Millions
our world is far more complex than
people realize and by extension even the
smallest impacts to the supply chain can
truly impact the world for example if
during the pandemic you tried to
purchase toilet paper you know what I
mean
as I said the Beating Heart of our
economy is logistics and here in the U.S
it represents nearly 10 percent of GDP
however there's a dirty underbelly of
logistics over 25 percent of global
emissions are attributable to the
movement of goods around the world and
solving the environmental footprint of
the backbone of modern human trade is
necessary if we want to solve the
climate crisis
so
what are we supposed to do
recycle
bring a reusable bag
struggle through using a paper straw
that melts in your mouth
no these all suffer from the same
Collective action problem that results
in only seven percent of plastic being
recycled here in the U.S and of that
seven percent ninety-five percent of it
ends up in the landfill anyway your
plastic cup isn't the ultimate problem
here to be frank you and I as
individuals can't do too much to solve
this problem while choosing three-day
shipping over next day shipping on your
next Amazon order it does help the
environment I can assure you it isn't
solving the climate crisis
however
sitting in front of me
are all of you
you represent the leaders of tomorrow
and today
you represent decision makers of Fortune
thousand companies leaders of
world-changing non-profits and our next
generation of intellectual capital
as Future Leaders you are some of the
best physician people in the world to do
something simple renew your supply chain
it's not very sexy
Forbes doesn't feature on the cover
people who are supply chain experts Time
Magazine won't write about you because
you've changed your supply chain and me
updating my Tinder bio to include
passionate about supply chain
transformation will not get me any more
matches
[Applause]
however given the complexified and
interwoven Supply chains that we live in
even the tiniest change by you as
leaders of the organizations that you
will lead can have a massive impact
for example here in the U.S idling is
about five percent of annual energy use
and there are two companies that have
turned this problem into a solution ups
and Staples
years ago UPS instituted a no left turns
program that was designed to avoid
waiting to cross traffic it helped them
reduce idling and save some money what
they did is they took GPS data they
programmed new routes they kind of took
cocentric circles to the right and as a
result they were able to save millions
of gallons per few of fuel per year
equivalent to 20 000 passenger vehicles
green supply chain strategies are not
novel nor do they have to be difficult
similarly Staples did something that
reduced the annual energy consumption of
their Fleet by 20 percent you know what
they did they told their drivers to go
slower by reducing their top speed to 60
miles per hour they were able to
increase their fuel efficiency from
eight and a half miles to 10 miles per
gallon saving them over 3 million
dollars per year
Supply chains are incredibly complex and
highly interwoven and as a result as I
said these tiny changes can have a
massive impact
so what can you do to help well what I
want you to do is ask yourself the
following question
how can I fix this and why do we do it
this way
and this question applies to the
entirety of your organization question
is why do we do it this way and I want
you to look at this from the entirety of
your organization from how we choose to
Source things to how you choose to
transport them to how you choose to
manufacture them to how you choose to
package them and finally to how
consumers consume them
after that it's easy for example Sam's
Club sells their milk in square
containers as opposed to traditional
containers it allows them to uh it
allows them to package things three
times tighter allowing them to use 60
fewer trucks than they used previously
and in Pakistan PepsiCo was able to
train farmers in sustainable growing
practices allowing their Farmers to
reduce the water consumption associated
with growing by 30 percent while at the
same time increasing crop yields by 30
percent
oh there's no lack of sexy Solutions
associated with improving our supply
chain however what all of them sometimes
don't recognize is that rather than
Reinventing the wheel sometimes we need
to work on the wheels themselves and by
focusing on supply chain strategies like
this we can have a truly tremendous
impact on the world we leave for future
Generations
you have the ability to change the world
by making tiny changes to the
organizations you lead and by doing
things as small as changing the
packaging you're using or maybe shipping
with a few days of extra lead time you
can have a tremendous impact on the
planet we leave for future Generations
my seven-year-old self was obsessed with
figuring out how things get from place
to place all I'm asking is that you
unlock the same curiosity in yourself
and be able to find the tiny tweaks to
your organizations that can change the
world thank you
[Applause]
[Music]